Well, I was thinking
I was very flattered about the fact that my sister committed suicide in 2007
And I had many questions from people online
Such as "I want to kill myself, what should I do?"
If she committed suicide
I do not even know, I do not even know what might happen
is yours
All I know is what will happen to the people who die after they die
I think it will be very, very harsh on your family
To live a normal life for a long time
(exhalation)
Hmm
If she committed suicide
People will miss you
Much
(inhalation)
Damn, I do not want to cry
Because if I cried I would not want to upload the video
But it is a message I want to deliver
(inhalation)
Hmm
Well, I apologize if I cried, I hate to modify things
When I cry, you just see yourself crying and this is strange and then you
The video is released and may take ten minutes, then you have to
The video is uploaded to the Internet, which takes time, so there is a process
In making the whole world see
That you cried at the moment you are watching
If she committed suicide
Your brother, your sister, your mother
Your friend, your lover, your girlfriend,
Your child. Or your child
(exhalation)
All these people. . . Who really, really love you
They will be puzzled
For the rest of their lives.
And they will be really angry
And. .
And jealousy right
I'm jealous
Of all who has a sister.
Did you know?
Six years have passed since her death.
It is still very difficult to talk about it
I mean in a real way
Because I can say a sentence here or there in a video.
(Inspiration) and so. . . It's a good feeling when you talk about it
Especially when I was trying to deliver a message
But
I mean, at the end of the day
As you know, there is someone. . . supposed to
Be in your life now.
But he is not here
They will never be here
probably. No, in fact, certainly. Because we all die.
But...
Uh
This event only forces you to ask yourself a lot of questions however
You will not get answers, but you will feel unnecessary pain
And a lot of depression and pain
It's a bad feeling very bad
And unfair
Then you have to wrestle with these same feelings over and over again every time
You think about it
So you try not to think about it,
But if you do not think about it
You can not get rid of pain
But healing and getting rid of pain is a very bad process
Because there is so much pain everywhere
Everywhere he turned to him, he was there!
It affects your character and who you are, there are who you were before the event and what it became after this event
Which I did, and because of that I am a different person
I do not know if it is for the better or for the worse
But I hate you and I love you
(Ins and Outs)
Just do not do it.
(Laughter)
(Cynical) just do not do it!
so stupid
Death is a stupid thing.
I do not like it
(exhalation)
But yes. I think this. . . (Laughter)
That's pretty much what. .
It will happen after you kill yourself.
to me . . .
Long, long time after the decision.
And if you have not made the decision
Like. . .
How many more years could you live?
To change things
(deep breath)
Keep two monks, Gotham.
Translation: GEX